everybody's talking about the metaverse
the metaverse seems to be the very next
step
in the co-evolution of humans and
technology the metaverse
reflects the latest iteration of the
human desire to virtualize reality or
rather the human desire to step into our
own
imagination
you see virtual reality it already
exists it's called storytelling when you
sit around the campfire you assume the
viewpoint of the central character as
the story unfolds and you leave the
ordinary world and enter the story world
of virtual reality or even better said a
reality of the virtual films perhaps
even richer and deeper and more
immersive story worlds more immersive
virtual realities archetypal realms
liminal realms theatrical realms where
we're basically dreaming while awake
places where our own inner psychic lives
can play out on screen right cinema is
like the mind meeting a version of its
own process there we are consciousness
externalized and reified moving into
stepping into living in our own
imaginations in these virtual realities
with these realities of the virtual and
so the metaverse is the latest moniker
of what is functionally the next step of
that the next level of immersiveness the
next level of absorption the next level
of participation the next level of
haptic feedback the next level of
creativity and gameplay the next level
of imaginative education instead of
learning through stories we'll learn
through virtual realities that we will
act out and have agency within we'll all
become heroes on a great quest it'll be
lord of the rings but instead of
passively watching will act out our
inner impulses it might be too much for
some but the metaverse again reflects
mankind's historical drive to manifest
his consciousness outside of his mind in
front of his eyes and i would say the
next step is to literally step through
the screen to step into the screen to
move into our own imaginations a kind of
a kind of interactive
theater like sleep no more that's always
on a new semiotic universe that we boot
up a new identity that we assume people
will take on avatars they'll free the
brave reckless gods that live inside of
them they'll run simulations and
simulacrums they'll explore new forms of
governance and communication and work
and play and sexuality we'll act things
out we'll try things out together it'll
be a dream space populated by many minds
reflecting again the human destiny of
stepping into our own imaginations as
terence mckenna the psychedelic
philosopher famously says it will lead
to new forms of human intimacy instead
of singing you a song which is amazing
or writing you a poem which is amazing
or showing you what my room which is
amazing or singing you a soliloquy which
is amazing instead i will invite you
into my innerverse i will invite you
into my waking dream i will invite you
into my virtual reality i will bring you
into a universe of my own construction
and we will dance together floating in
space like the characters of la la land
to the crescendo of the greatest song
ever as we sing the songs that
orchestrate the universe it'll be like
the end of the film interstellar where
time scales are collapsing into each
other through the power of love and we
do not go gentle into that good night
and we rage and rage and rage against
the dying of the light as we step
through wormholes and black holes and
become five-dimensional beings that have
free and brave reckless gods within us
because as ellen harrington said we must
never forget we are cosmic
revolutionaries not stew just
conscripted to advance a natural order
that kills everyone that is not our
destiny our destiny is to become the
stars right human speech is but a
cracked kettle on which we tap crude
rhythms while we long to make music that
will melt the stars well friends
understand me now what begins with
storytelling and movie watching and myth
making and theater and virtual reality
and the metaverse and stepping into our
imagination will will
will will crescendo at us
divinizing ourselves becoming divinity
becoming creativity becoming poetry stop
trying to make art and just become art
friends that is our birthright that is
our destiny that is why we will not go
gentle into that good night and rage and
sing and dance forever and ever against
the dying of the light and we will sing
the songs that orchestrate the universe
and we will drink the wine of centuries
unborn and nothing less will do and i
want nothing less for me and i want
nothing less for you for this is our
common ecstasy so friends virtual
reality the metaverse it's only a step
function let us not miss the plot or the
through line let us not miss where this
is going the omega point of unleashing
ourselves and denizing ourselves and
exploring ourselves and expanding
ourselves and facing the reality of
ourselves and redefining ourselves and
literally the imagination summoning its
own literalization this is the
five-dimensional future pulling the
present forward to meet it this is
literally the imagination disney's
fantasia perhaps think of mickey mouse
becoming the wizard you know or esther's
hands where the hand is drawing the hand
that's drawing the hand we create and
perceive our world do you realize that
what we're speaking about here and this
is the moment where the imagination
summons its own literalization where the
imagination summons its own
literalization and through biotechnology
and nanotechnology we will pattern dna
and write poetry with atoms and turn the
world into a programmable media medium
and literally flew into our own
imaginations as it summons its own
literalization and we free the brave
reckless gods within us all and that
friends starts with the metaverse
it's a world of pure imagination
of pure
imagination